captain - away team set phasers to
revival you know I'm not gonna go back
through every video I've ever done to
double-check this but this might be my
first time talking directly about Star
Trek which is weird but yeah so some
Star Trek news to talk about coming from
Patrick Stewart and apparently with a
kind of sort of continuation on the next
generation he's gotta be playing the
part of Captain jean-luc Picard yet
again so I suppose a little bit about my
feelings in my relationship with Star
Trek since like is that I haven't talked
about it before Star Trek is one of the
sort of the major geek interests as far
as franchises go that I Amba least
invested in while still enjoying it it's
not like I mean there are some that I'm
just like I never got into or I never
tried or any other things like Babylon 5
or supernatural you know there's a whole
buncha stuff I just never got to it all
but Star Trek is something that I enjoy
but like there's no series of Star Trek
that I've seen every episode of I've
seen all the movies that's kind of it
and I have seen some episodes of some of
the series but you know I'm not I'm
absolutely not hardcore I'm like I am a
very casual Star Trek fan that said next
generation that's my jam you know that
was the that was the Star Trek show that
I care the most about is the one I've
seen the most episodes of it's the cast
I feel like I know the best and I am
there's a couple of things that make me
very about the notion of continuing with
characters from something like the next
generation now the the wording from what
I can find is actually pretty specific
they're not calling it a reboot they're
not even calling it necessarily bringing
the show back because the only
character they're talking about right
now is jean-luc Picard is Patrick
Stewart in that role now I would be
shocked if we don't get at least cameo
appearances by a heck of a lot of the
rest of the cast but it looks like they
are framing this not as the continued ow
you know out into space missions of the
enterprise as captained by jean-luc
Picard but the continued Adventures of
jean-luc Picard himself which may or may
not involve the enterprise and the rest
of the crew because as much as
oftentimes the captain becomes the
default main character of Star Trek they
are all of them ensemble pieces and this
at least from what they're making it
sound like sounds a little bit more
focused on him specifically there are a
few reasons that it makes me nervous
the first is you talk about reviving
anything that was off that's been off
the air for that long it's gonna make me
inherently nervous just because I can't
not get nervous about it and but I'm
also a little bit worried about Patrick
Stewart in himself and I need to be
really clear on why Patrick Stewart is
an excellent actor he was an excellent
actor then he's an excellent actor now
this is not a Robert DeNiro situation
where like he's you have to start to
wonder like what's he ever really that
good and then you'd go back and watch
the old stuff and go oh yeah he was he
just it's not what he does anymore
Patrick Stewart is still good he's still
very good I mean you look at something
like Logan he Hugh Mann but the thing is
who he is as a person and I think
arguably also as an actor is
fundamentally different from when he was
playing jean-luc Picard especially when
he started playing jean-luc Picard he
rather famously was I mean quit he had a
stick up his butt basically he himself
relayed the story of being on set on the
next generation and the other actors
were you know somebody flubbed a line
and they're all sort of laughing about
it he chides them for laughing and
somebody says a
come on Patrick we're just trying to
have fun and he chided them we are not
here to have fun very super serious
that's who he was
that's not who he is now as a person and
that's not me making a judgment call
that one is better or is one is worse or
that the acting of a man who took
himself more seriously than takes
himself less seriously now is better or
worse in either case but it is
fundamentally different and it's gonna
he since he as a person is in such a
different place now than where he was
then I worry about what that means for
how he's going to approach this
character now it could feasibly be the
best thing for it because it will allow
the character to grow and it's not just
him playing the character exactly as he
did you know 20 years ago or whatever
and and even though the character
theoretically should have been through
enough life experiences that he's not
gonna be exactly the same so maybe the
fact that he's changed will allow him to
imbue that into the character or maybe
because he is such a different person
than he was certainly when he was
playing this character for for a TV
schedule and Piatt and I would say
possibly even since the last time he
played it in film that he just won't
connect and build the character too into
anything that we recognize as jean-luc
Picard I think both of those are
possibilities and that makes me a little
bit nervous on a fundamental level I did
I I also get annoyed that Star Trek has
a moving forward problem like a big one
at this point and they haven't been very
clear about timeline on this because I
think it is I suppose as possible that
technically speaking this might finally
be the first thing since the discovery
that takes place later in the timeline
than that because after discovery went
off the air
as far as what's gone on
it was enterprise and then the movies
got rebooted so we're dealing with Kirk
again and then it's discovery which is
even
for that and it the this you know what
it is
Star Trek became what I said I would I
would be terrified that dr. who would
become if they ever had the doctor
regenerate into an actor who had already
played the part which is that Star Trek
has become navel-gazing it's all about
looking in at itself and its examination
ins and its feelings about its own
history and its own lore and legacy and
the show has not moved forward in time
or in theme or in really any massive
significant way at a long time it's
either been riffing on repeating or
deconstructing its own history it's
become the snake eating its own tail and
the idea of revisiting jean-luc Picard
unfortunately kind of fits in with that
in a way that also kind of makes me go
hmm that being said I'm gonna be very
curious to keep an eye on this project
and find out what gets said about it
later on down the road as things
actually fall into place as we get more
information on a timeline as we get more
information about where this is gonna be
set is this gonna be set on a Space
Station is this gonna be set on an alien
world and basically stay there like has
he taken up residence on a planet or a
station or is it a ship that's gonna go
from planet to planet which would
effectively make it just like the
enterprise but I will be very curious to
find out more details more specifics
about what it is they're doing the
approach that they have and sort of what
the thematic goal and intent is because
I can't help but think basically about
the last episode of next generation all
good things and there because that's a
three timeline story one of them being a
far future and I can't help but think
about that and I do get a little misty
thinking about that because I really
love that episode I thought it was a but
I think it's one of the better one of
the
best season series finales that's been
done it's right up there and I love it
so despite all my reservations there is
part of me that thinks about Patrick's
you know Patrick Stewart old intending
to a vineyard you know that image from
that episode and going oh yeah sort of
getting that nostalgia twinge so it's
it's there's still there's something in
me that is enough of a fan of Star Trek
and of Picard because Picard is my
favorite captain and and that's probably
largely nostalgia but I don't care and
there is you know there is something
that still connects on that level with
me so I want this to work but you know I
get I get called a bit over analytical a
bit of a killjoy or as some folks in the
podcasting sphere I've come to call me
the professional buzzkill I can't turn
that part of my brain off I can't help
it I see where the problems might be but
I hope I'm wrong because as Patrick
Stewart is getting older I I really want
him to be dedicating his time to things
that are gonna be memorable and
inventive and new things for him you
know I didn't I didn't watch Blount talk
but I remember seeing the trailers and
go nice that feels like the kind of
thing he should be doing you know going
out on a limb trying something different
and and I hope they can find a way even
though he is going back to a character
that is his most iconic role arguably
other than Professor Xavier possibly I
would say more so and you know hopefully
finding a way to to still have that be
something new something a little bit
different we'll see I probably won't
have anything Star Trek related to talk
about again for a while I still haven't
watched any of Discovery I really need
to I'm trying desperately to catch up on
stuff from last year before we get into
the fall TV season and a lot of stuff
starts up again but I'm not make as much
progress as I
planned but we'll leave it off there
Star Trek The Next Generation Captain
Picard in the captain's seat again or
maybe now we don't know where he's gonna
be but whatever your thoughts are on
this drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it they're all there's
all this stuff to do i'm unfortunately
gonna be pushing specifically the
Twitter and the Facebook a little bit
harder just for logistical reasons you
may or may not have heard that a lot of
youtubers are having their videos not
show up in people's subscription feeds
even though they should even if those
people have hit the bell so if the only
way you keep up with what I've been
doing is through YouTube and your
subscription feed it's distinctly
possible that if you aren't already you
may soon be missing stuff because
YouTube is really messing with anybody
that isn't humongous so I would
recommend
additionally either liking the Facebook
page or following me on Twitter because
I do put notifications in both those
places every time I've got a new video
and of course same with the patreon
that's the other big one so sorry to do
more of an exit ramble on stuff but you
know YouTube's being kind of a jerk as a
platform so there you go in any case
there's links for those things and a
whole bunch of other stuff it's all down
in the description remember folks you
are the council I just run the meeting
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]